الى تطورات على الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه حيث اعلن حزب الله استهدافه
التجهيزات التجسسيه في موقع الرادار
الاسرائيلي في مزارع شبعه المحتله مؤكدا
تحقيقه اصابه مباشره وافاد مراسل الجزيره
بان المدفعيه الاسرائيليه قصفت محيط بلده
الهبار في القطاع الشرقي في من جنوب لبنان
بالاضافه الى محيط بلدتي ارين
والبستان في هذه الاثناء نقلت صحيفه دعوت
احرنوت الاسرائيليه ان اكثر من 500 منزل
ومبنى في الجليل الاعلى تضررت بنيران حزب
الله منذ اندلاع الحرب واشارت الى ان
بلدات المطله ولومي والمناره هي الاكثر
تضررا وتعرضا لضربات حزب الله ولفتت
الصحيفه الى زياده مرضه في استخدام الحزب
لصواريخ بركان وفلق واحد الثقيله كما نقلت
يدعوت احرنوت عن رئيس مجلس بلده شلومي ان
سقوط صواريخ بركان على البلده اصبح اكثر
تكرارا وانها اصبحت في خطر
حقيقي معنا من الجليل الاعلى مراسل
الجزيره حسان مسعود ومن مرجع عيون جنوبي
لبنان مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقده ابدا
معك ايهاب العقده واخر معطيات عمليات
القصف والقصف المتبادل على طول الشريط
الحدودي سمعنا منذ بعض الوقت انفجارا داخل
المستوطنه المطلي بعد انطلاق صافرات
الانذار هناك ربما في خلفيه الصوره يمكن
مشاهده ال الدخان الذي تصاعد من جراء
عمليه الاستهداف التي وقعت على مستوطنه
المطلي قبل دقائق من الان مستوطنه المطلي
سبق وان استهدفها حزب الله
بصاروخ او بصاروخين على الاقل لاحد
المنازل التي يتحصن فيها الجنود
الاسرائيليون يوم امس وحقق اصابات وفقا
للبيان الذي اعلنه كانت ايضا هذه المنطقه
تعرضت لاستهداف اخرى من جانب حزب الله
خصوصا وانها تعرضت اصبحت عمليا سكنه
عسكريه منذ الثامن من اكتوبر بعد ان اخلاه
المستوطنون هنا وذهبوا باتجاه العمق
الاسرائيلي هذا اليوم شن حزب الله هجوما
على موقع الرادار فو فوق مزارع فوق بلده
شبعه وهو الموقع الذي يطل على البلده
ويحمي مزارع شب
التي تحتلها اسرائيل ويتصل هذا الموقع
بمواقع اخرى على تلال كفر شوبه وباتجاه
الجولان السوري المحتل حزب الله كان
الليله الماضيه استهدف كذلك منزلا في
مستوطنه المناره التي تقع قباله ميس الجبل
في القطاع الاوسط من جنوب لبنان
استهدفها بالصواريخ وقال انه حقق اصابه
مباشره هذا جزء طبعا من سلسله العمليات
التي تجري في جنوب لبنان والتي شنها حزب
الله خصوصا يوم امس وبلغ عددها سبع
هجمات بعضها استخدم فيها حزب الله
الصواريخ التي تحمل رؤوسا متفجره شديده
الانفجار باتجاه المواقع الاسرائيليه
وتجمعات الجنود في مناطق مختلفه من جنوب
لبنان واعلن حزب الله كذلك عن استهداف
لدبابه ميركافا في القطاع قباله القطاع
الاوسط في احد المواقع اسرائيليه وقال انه
حقق اصابه ب هذذه الصواريخ التي استهدفها
فيها هذه الدبابه طبعا الجبهه لبنان هي
جبهه مشتعله وهي ايضا تتصل كذلك بالجهود
الدبلوماسيه التي بدات القوى السياسيه
المختلفه الدوليه بحث لبنان على اتخاذ
اجراءات بالنسبه لجنوب لبنان هذا اليوم
وصل وزير خارجيه بريطانيا ديفيد مالبن الى
لبنان لحث المسؤولين على اتخاذ اجراءات
ترتبط بالوضع في جنوب لبنان وبتطبيق
القرار 1701 وهو التقى رئيس حكومه تصريف
الاعمال نجيب مقاطي هذا اليوم وفقا لمكتب
ميقاتي الذي اصدر بيانا بهذا الشان وبشان
اللقاء الذي جر في الحديث عن مساله جنوب
لبنان والقرار 1701 وضروره تعزيز دور
الجيش والتعاون مع قوات اليونيفل العامله
في جنوب لبنان منذ عام 2006 حسان مسعود
بنقل عن مراسلتنا صفارات الانذار تدوي في
منطقه المطله باصبع ليل على الحدود مع
لبنان اذا المعطيات ايضا حيث انت هي
تتتالى تماما سلمى بينما نتحدث الان تدوي
سفرات الانذار في بلده الاطله الواقعه على
الحدود مع لبنان في اصبع الجليل وقد سمعنا
قبل لحظات فقط صوت انفجار في تلك المنطقه
هذه المنطقه الواقعه هنا
خلفنا في المطله تحديدا بعد لحظات فقط من
اعلان دوي صفرات الانذار وطلب الجبهه
الداخليه من السكان التوجه فورا الى
الملاجئ وهذا اتى بعد سماع انفجارات ايضا
خلال الساعات الماضيه في ذات
المنطقه في محيطها وحتى هذه اللحظه لم
يعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي عن موقع الاستهداف
او عن طبيعه هذا الاستهداف
وا نتائج هذه الضربه التي سمعنا دويها من
هنا ما اذا كان قد اعترض احد الصواريخ في
سماء المنطقه او ما اذا كان قد تم حدوث
استهداف ما في هذه المنطقه وا الظروف
الجويه ايضا تحول دون تمكننا من رؤيه اثار
هذه الضربه التي سمعناها قبل لحظات فقط
لكن ايه ما ذكرته صحيفه يدعوت احرنوت خلال
تقرير مفصل لها عن واقع الجبهه الشماليه
يشير الى حجم الاضرار التي ايه شهدتها هذه
الجبهه منذ السابع من اكتوبر وحتى اليوم
حيث اشارت الى تضرر 500 منزل نعم بشكل كلي
او جزئي خلال هذه الضربات لا سما في
المطله ولومي والمناره ا شكرا لك حسان
مسعود من الجليل الاعلى وايضا ايهاب
العقده من مرج عيون جنوبي لبنان